it would be taylor hearn to pitch for
the rangers tonight this is his fourth
start
is that one line down the low and so he
takes one right away from crawford and
that's out number one
2-2
and they get him to chase away that
strikeout ends the inning a 1-2-3 for
taylor hearn now these rangers bats
ready to go to work tyler anderson
acquired starting pitcher from the
pirates at the trade deadline making yet
another start against texas
now the one two
swinging a fly ball into shallow right
field and down the line hanniga on the
run reaches out slides and he makes the
catch
holy smokes he wiped out the chalk on
the right field line at the last second
he was running out of room went into
that protective slide as the seats curl
around toward the right field line
haniger with an outstanding catch
robbing keiner for leftover for the
second out of the inning what a play
now he has done some damage to the
mariners this year swinging away and
with that anderson retires the side in
order collects his first strike out of
the night
hard hit on the ground to the point of
the shift and past the dive of a bonies
sleeper says i will see your shifts and
hit it right through it second hitting a
rudder at first nobody out and the pitch
he struck him out swinging i threw him a
changeup and then a slider to get him
two strikeouts for hearn taylor
averaging just over a strikeout per
inning this year
it's been a struggle for the rookie and
he hits this one on the ground down to
first low will take it himself and that
will do it in the second inning so hearn
puts up another zero
second strikeout for tyler anderson who
has sat down the first five in a row
there's 2-1
then this one is in the air the other
way down the line that could be trouble
drops in base hit hannah
got there in time to take it on a hop
but that was just too long a run for him
to get to it and culverson drops the
little hand grenade in for a single
second and third
o2 pitch this ball belted to center
field but kellnick
has time and space to get to it and he
does inning is over rangers leave a
couple
this is into right field for a base hit
cal raleigh makes the turn to third
j.p crawford picks up a base hit
brings up ty france struck out on a 2-2
pitch first time huh france
out towards right center
calraly at third base is on his way home
he scores crawford tiptoes into third
and the mariners get on the board first
it's a sac fly by ty france in the third
inning one-nothing mariners andy ibanez
lead it off for the rangers
[Applause]
got under this one deep out to left
field near the wall
just gets it out to left
the rangers are on the board this one
tied at one
all right another glimpse at some of
that power and ibanez's bat his fifth
home run of the year
swings right through a meatball for out
number three after three innings title
one
shoots this out to shadow center and it
dunks in for a base hit
raleigh is aboard for the second time
it's a one out single
pole and this time he gets paid off of
the base hit
cal raleigh motors into third base
meanwhile jp going into second raleigh
is held at third
and j.p crawford
on board for the second time
parents have a couple in scoring
position a chance to get the lead back
reaching for it
a drive out to center field calrody
getting ready to come home once again
cal scores meanwhile crawford is into
third we've seen this movie before
tonight
mitch haniger this time a sac fly out to
center field and the mariners now lead
it two to one in the fifth inning last
time up he lined out to right field
and he pops this one up
hanging up there forever
dj peters gets to it one away here in
the sixth inning
he's a swing and a miss
by fraley as a strikeout to complete an
eighth pitch
sixth inning for dennis santana
into center kelnick
ranging back putting it away two pitches
went out
he got him upstairs anderson three
strikeouts facing adolesce garcia he
retires the side in order 12 in a row
3-2
kellnick draws a one-out-one
county kid's running the swing of the
miss throw down a second and they got
him
kellnick gunned down and it wasn't even
close
two gone in the inning
and they see jonaheim's strong accurate
arm again
santana's two two pitch and he swings
and misses strike three so the strikeout
ends it three strikeouts in two winnings
for dennis santana
there's a fastball top of the zone swing
and a miss down goes peters there's
pitch swung on
by low coming in killing it coming in a
hurry sliding catch well done two down
he had a long run he was playing deep
for low he came into this a b o for two
and heim swings that one's laced up the
middle in the center field of base hit
so jonah now with two hits couple of
singles and the rangers with two outs
here in the bottom of the seventh keep
things going the big pitch the 3-2 to
martin
he got him this time top of the zone
martin retired i'm stranded
here's the payoff
ball four
why not walk to haniger who reaches for
the first time seeger coming to the
plate
chris woodward has the lefty
brett martin loose in the bullpen and so
that's an easy decision martin will be
coming on here with the eighth in a
one-run game
in the air
out to right center peters
calls for it makes the play and the
inning is done so martin gets it done
2-2
inside and that one hit
hernandez
on the ground tough play crawford gets
rid of it on the first base what a
double play
flashing some gold j.p crawford gets the
mariners out of an ain't getting jam two
outs top of the ninth two one mariners
lead and that'll bring up luis terence
this is smokes
deep out to right center field and oh my
goodness oh it's gone it's gone
peters looked like he had it he did for
a second
had it for a split second
had his glove turned the wrong way and
the force of hitting the fence caused it
to go into the bullpen and that'll be a
home run for terence there's some
insurance
number 14 for luis terrence for a moment
was a spectacular catch instead
it's a much needed run for the mariners
[Applause]
on the ground and that one is through
base hit so he is aboard in the ninth
and garcia and seawall that seems to be
a favorable matchup for the rangers
another high target
shot out towards left center kalnik
makes the catch for the final out of the
ball game seawalled locks it down the
mariners get a game one win yeah nice
way to start the road trip not a lot of
offense from the mariners but the
pitching was outstanding including
anderson going six innings giving up
just the one run and then turn it over
to the strength of your ball club the
back end of your bullpen
you